Yo bienvenue dans le troisième épisode du Coup de Phil'
Cette fois ci on va étudier un truc de ouf !
Trop stylé !
Qui déchire sa mère !
Et ça s'appelle le divertissement Pascalien.
C'était cool cette intro nan?
C'est mieux quand ça va vite plutôt que quand ça va doucement
Vous ne trouvez pas?
C'est normal
Quand j'vais super vite avec pleins d'animations partout, j'occupe l'attention de ton cerveau,
alors que quand ça va lentement,
l'attention de ton cerveau est libre.
Du coup tu te fais chier.
Et on déteste se faire chier.
Bah ouais, dès qu'on est sans rien faire, on se retrouve face à soi-même et à des pensées négatives
liées au fait que je sois mortel,
comme par exemple : Quel est le sens de ma vie ?
Qu'est-ce que je dois accomplir avant ma mort?
Ou encore: Y-a-t il une vie après la mort?
"Quel est mon but dans la vie?"
"Est-ce que j'ai un destin?"
"Pourquoi suis-je sur Terre?"
"Y'a Nabila à la télé"
"J'arrive!"
Du coup, on va vouloir occuper notre attention à quelque chose pour éviter d'être dans cet état de pensée.
Et c'est ça qu'on appelle : le Divertissement Pascalien.
Cela nous vient de Blaise Pascal né en 1623 à Clermont-Ferrand
"Big up à tous les clermontois gros"
Alors en fait il voulait écrire un livre qui s'appelle "L'apologie de la religion chrétienne".
Mais il n'a pas pu parce qu'il est mort avant.
Donc, on a récupéré toutes ses pensées, qu'il avait écrites sur des petits bouts de papier,
et on en a fait un livre posthume qui s'appelle "Les pensées".
T'imagines on fait un livre avec tes pensées?
"Les pensées"
Pour occuper mon attention à quelque chose,
je vais devoir trouver une activité comme jouer ou mater du porno.
Mais pas seulement,
le divertissement Pascalien c'est aussi aller en cours,
faire de la physique, et même travailler pour gagner sa vie.
En fait, c'est tout ce qui nous évite de penser à des questions existentielles.
"Voilà enfin merci de préciser que la science est aussi un divertissement
et qu'il n'y a pas que les films pornographi..."
Ce qu'il faut éviter c'est de prendre ses divertissements trop au sérieux
et d'oublier que derrière tout ça, bah y'a nous.
L'essentiel !
C'est vrai que certains se perdent dans le jeu,
et donnent au divertissement une place trop importante par rapport à ce qu'il devrait avoir.
Je pense par exemple à tous ceux qui sont criblés de dettes
parce qu'ils ont trop joué aux jeux d'argent
ou même pire ceux qui crèvent devant les jeux vidéo.
Genre ce mec à Taïwan,
qui a joué pendant 23h à League of Legends, et qui est mort devant LOL
Le mec n'a même pas eu le temps de finir sa grenadine
Alors je sais pas si c'est à cause du jeu mais il m'a l'air aussi un peu crispé
Ah il est mort ? D'accord
Quand on se donne ces divertissements,
on se crée une illusion pour éviter de penser à tous ces trucs chiants.
Pascal appelle ça "se piper"
"Encore?"
Oui.
Apparemment ça se fait facilement en se cassant les deux côtes.
Et dès qu'on a finit un divertissement on va le remplacer par un autre,
c'est pour ça qu'on adore les playlists, par exemple.
Un peu comme Austin Power:
quand il a sa femme tout va bien, il se divertit et quand elle crève,
ben... faut bien se divertir de nouveau.
Le pouvoir de l'imagination peut nous aider aussi énormément à nous divertir.
Je suis sûr que vous vous êtes déjà fait tellement chier
que vous avez regardé les nuages et que vous leur avez donné des noms
en fonction de leur formes.
"Hé les gars, vous trouvez pas que ce nuage on dirait un dauphin avec ces yeux là?"
"Un dauphin? T'es vraiment un pd toi, on dirait une grosse teub ouai"
"Mais pas du tout, ça ressemble à un gros caca! A du caca ! Personne voit le caca ici?"
"Du coup se divertir c'est se mettre des feintes un peu, c'est pas bien"
En fait, c'est pas que c'est pas bien.
Le truc c'est que Pascal dit lui même
que sans divertissement, il n'y a pas de joie donc c'est essentiel pour l'Homme de se divertir.
Or, se divertir c'est se détourner de l'essentiel.
Donc c'est essentiel de se détourner de l'essentiel.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un paradoxe.
Par contre, ce qui est mauvais pour Pascal c'est prendre le divertissement trop au sérieux et se perdre dedans.
Et c'est ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure.
Après, faut savoir que Pascal n'est pas le premier à en avoir parlé, il y a aussi Sénéque.
Mais, Pascal apporte une grosse dimension chrétienne qu'on a pas du tout vu dans cette vidéo.
Mais je préfère vous le dire.
Merci beaucoup pour vos encouragements ça me fait vachement plaisir.
J'ai créé un compte Twitter, n'hésitez pas à aller voir.
Je dis, par exemple, où j'en suis à la création de mes vidéos.
Si vous voulez suivre un petit peu,
ou si vous voulez me contacter c'est plus facile.
En attendant n'hésitez pas à passer le coup de Phil' à un ami, c'est-à-dire partagez cette vidéo.
Et on se retrouve pour une prochaine fois, pour un prochain épisode, pour un prochain coup de Phil' !